welcome to today's press conference the
ministers have some opening remarks and
then afterwards we'll get to questions
uh we'll start in the room and then on
on the zoom line
uh with that in mind uh deputy prime
minister when you're ready the floor is
yours
okay
good morning
today i'm announcing that canada will be
the first country to revoke russia's and
guilarusa's most favored nation status
as a trading partner under canadian law
we are working closely with our partners
and allies to encourage them to take the
same step simply put
this means that russia and belarus will
no longer receive the benefits
particularly low tariffs
that canada offers to other countries
that are fellow members of the wto
instead
russia and belarus will be subject to a
tariff of 35
on their exports to canada
the only other country that does not
enjoy mfn status with canada is
north korea
last night we also announced that canada
will sanction 10 executives from rosneft
russia's leading oil company and from
gazprom a major russian state-owned
energy company
this will bring the total number of
people and entities sanctioned or in the
process of being sanctioned by canada
since russia's illegal occupation of
crimea in 2014
to more than 1 000.
as we have been saying since the
beginning
of russia's barbaric invasion of ukraine
we will do everything in our power
to make sure
that president putin
his accomplices
those who allow him to do so and see
it and the russian economy to pay the
price
[Music]
members of the russian financial elite
may believe that their close ties
to western boardrooms and yacht clubs
will protect them
but they're wrong
and russian institutions
that are central to president putin's
fallen cryptocurrencies
enjoy this prosperity
whose very
foundations
the g7 has already imposed the strongest
sanctions ever inflicted on a major
economy on russia
and more will follow in the days to come
the ruble has been down by as much as 30
percent this week
on monday russia's central bank raised
its benchmark interest rate to 20
the russian stock market is closed today
for the fourth consecutive day
moody's and fitch have now downgraded
russian government debt
to junk
status
the economic costs of the kremlin's
barbaric war
are already high
and they will continue to rise
for the remarkable ukrainian people
who are so courageously resisting his
assault
for more details on our support
for the ukrainian people
i turned the floor over to my colleague
the minister of immigration refugees and
citizenship canada sean freeze sean
frazier
and sean now over to you
uh thank you so much uh good afternoon
uh or good morning
uh
canada
is ready to welcome ukrainians fleeing
vladimir putin's war and there is no
limit to the number of applications that
we are going to be willing to accept
canada
ukraine
will welcome ukrainians seeking to flee
the reason for our commitment goes
beyond the historic ties between canada
and ukraine it goes beyond the cultural
connections between our people
i can't help but think that centuries
from now historians will be writing of
the courage on display in ukraine today
from the fearless leadership of
president zielinski to the young fathers
with tears in their eyes delivering
their children to safety before they
return to the front lines to fight in a
war that they never wanted but know that
they have to win to the unarmed
grandmothers confronting russian
soldiers telling them that they ought to
place seeds in their pockets so that
sunflowers may grow while their bodies
rest on ukrainian soil
these are these stories of courage in
the stories of heroes that are going to
be told for generations to come
uh
we believe in the principles of
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
nations we believe in the right of
peoples to self-determination
these are the values that underpin the
founding documents of the united nations
and form the basis of the international
rules-based legal order that has helped
deliver peace and prosperity to
canadians for the better part of a
century
but if we fail to breathe life into
these important texts by choosing not to
defend the principles behind the
documents when they are under attack
then they are worth no more than the
paper on which they are written
that's why we're launching two new
special programs for ukrainians who want
to come to canada temporarily and for
those who wish to stay
for those who need a safe haven while
the war ravages their homeland we are
creating the canada ukraine
authorization for emergency travel
ukraine authorization for emergency
travel no limit
on the number of applications accepted
under this stream
the primary motivation for this new
program is that it provides the fastest
way for us to start welcoming as many
ukrainians as possible and will allow
them to stay for a period of up to two
years
we're waiving most of the requirements
that exist under a traditional visa
in order to qualify individuals we'll
need to complete a simple application
form and provide biometrics for security
and background screening
to help ensure this process can be
executed in a timely way we started
moving biometric kits and other
materials to the region in mid-january
this means that we have both the
equipment and personnel in place to take
biometrics in warsaw vienna and
bucharest in addition to 30 other
location locations throughout europe
we're ready to extend hours of operation
and add more staff as needed where
needed
everyone who arrives under this new
stream will also be eligible for an open
work permit or study permit that will
allow them to take a job with any
canadian employer or enroll in an
education program
a commonal
application fees to remove the
additional financial burden for families
any canadian employer willing to hire
ukrainians may do so
and i encourage the canadian business
community to step up and do their part
to help support those coming into canada
in their time of need and i want to say
thank you to the employers who've
already reached out saying that you want
to do your part
i've heard from the ukrainian-canadian
community that many fleeing the violence
will want to return to their homeland
and to their families when the war comes
to an end
i've heard that others particularly
those with family in canada may wish to
stay
that is why we are also introducing an
expedited path to permanent residency
for ukrainians seeking to reunite with
family members who are already in canada
through a new family sponsorship program
that is why we are also introducing an
expertise
family members who are already in canada
will allow a wider circle of family
members to be resettled in canada
compared to traditional family
reunification streams we're going to be
working closely with members of the
ukrainian canadian community and the
ukrainian canadian congress in
particular to finalize the details of
this new program in the coming weeks
more than a month ago we also moved to
implement priority processing for
ukrainians who wish to reunite with
families study work or start a new life
here in
canada here
or canada
over six thousand ukrainians in canada
under these programs
we have also launched a dedicated
immigration hotline an online
application form for ukraine available
in canada
we are unwavering in our commitment to
do whatever it takes as long as it takes
to help you succeed in your efforts to
win this war
we will provide equipment to help defend
your homeland we will provide financial
support to help stabilize your economy
we will impose economic sanctions on
your oppressor and today we will offer
safe haven to your families while you
fight on the front lines of a war to
defend your freedom from tyranny to the
benefit of the entire world thank you
merci lemon
and i think it's over to the minister of
defense anita now now
merci beaucoup thank you christian
good morning bonjour tulmont it has been
just over one week since russia further
invaded and brutally attacked ukraine
one week of witnessing the horrific
consequences of putin's unprovoked war
on innocent people and one week of
unshakable courage for
our ukrainian friends
while putin's attacks have steadily
intensified so has our military support
for ukraine in coordination with our
allies
we will leave no stone unturned when it
comes to supporting our friends in
ukraine
as they fight for their lives and their
right to exist
to this end i am announcing today
in addition to the various tranches of
military equipment that we have pledged
to in the last 30 days
to
new significant contributions
first we intend to supply additional
lethal aid to ukraine which includes up
to 4 500
m72 rocket launchers and up to 7 500
hand grenades
these weapons will be drawn from the
canadian armed forces existing
stockpiles and will be transported to
the region as quickly
and safely as possible
given the nature of the conflict we are
not providing details relating to
transit
second we will be providing ukraine with
one million dollars towards the purchase
of high resolution
modern satellite imagery
this capability
will provide ukraine's military with a
strengthened ability to monitor the
movement of russian forces in and around
their territory
we will do everything that we can to
support
our ukrainian
quickly and safely as possible
secondly
will
in the measures we take are informed by
constant conversations
with our allies and with ukraine
i am in daily contact
also with minister resnikoff
and yesterday i spoke with
nato secretary general jens stoltenberg
and the defense ministers of denmark
norway and sweden
as we see the horrific impacts of
putin's aggression
we must continue to remember
that our allies and partners are united
and that we are going to keep adding to
the measures
to support ukraine's sovereignty
security
and territorial integrity
the brutality
of what we're seeing on our screens is
angry
everyone
more violent
conflict
ukraine
canada and the rest of the world want or
need
and that is the goal of our partners and
allies only putin knows what putin will
do and it is our job
to do everything we can to protect as
many lives as possible together with our
nato allies as the minister of national
defense my commitment
our government's commitment is to
continue to do exactly that in the hours
days and weeks to come
thank you merci beaucoup
okay we're gonna get started with
questions in the room one question one
follow rachel
hi ministers rachel haynes from ctv
national news uh my question is for
minister freeland um about the sanctions
you talked about how the g7 has already
issued some of the strongest sanctions
and that there are more to come however
other g7 allies have come under fire for
not doing enough to sanction individuals
like boris johnson in the uk
um
are you noticing any type of impact that
these sanctions are actually having on
vladimir putin's behavior as we're
seeing there has been a bombardment of
all these cities hospitals and increased
shelling in kiev are these sanctions
actually having an impact
uh the sanctions are absolutely having
an impact
and that's why i outlined in my remarks
the very significant impact our measures
are having directly on the russian
economy
so you know ruble down 30
interest rates up to 20
fitch and moody's downgrading russian
debt to junk the stock exchange closed
for the fourth day in a row this is a
significant and direct impact which is
already being felt by every single
person in russia and that's a really big
deal because let's remember the toughest
measures only came into force on monday
morning when it comes to the individuals
the oligarchs and the people in putin's
inner circle who are being sanctioned
this is definitely having an impact as
well
these are people who
have
tried to have it both ways
for a long time
they're people who have
been hangers on of lagumer putin his
sycophants his enablers as he has become
more and more of a threat to the world
but at the same time they have enjoyed
a pretty
fabulous lifestyle in the west with
yachts and mansions and having their
kids at the fanciest universities and
private schools
and what we've done with these measures
much more forcefully than the russian
elite anticipated
is we have said you know what
you have to pick sides
and i can tell you it is having an
impact and one
concrete way that we are seeing that
impact
is some of the oligarchs
are starting to speak out
that's what they're say if that's what
they're saying in public
imagine what conversations are happening
within the kremlin and inside russia and
that's exactly what needs to happen
and you know i do want
the russian leadership to understand
russian oligarchs to understand
we're going to keep on going
there is a tremendous willingness among
the world's democracies
to just continue ratcheting up the
pressure
and
as i hope the russian leadership has
seen
we are being very creative
we are using tools which no one
would even have imagined deploying just
a week ago and there's more to come
what kind of conversations have you been
having with your allies or i'm sure you
don't probably won't go into specifics
in public probably you normally tell us
you don't like to tell us your
negotiations in public but um in terms
of the uk specifically where there have
been calls for them to do more um
have you had any direct conversations
with your counterparts in the uk about
doing more 100 yeah i am in close touch
with chancellor rishi sunek uh i spoke
to him over the weekend
he and i text each other
several times a day
and of course he and i were both at the
g7 finance ministers meeting early on
tuesday morning and we had a quick
follow-up phone call the two of us
afterwards to talk about follow-on
actions
i really
believe and i think we see this in the
actions
that all of our g7 partners
are
extremely
resolute and determined to continue
ratcheting up the pressure there is a
real
unity of
will
unity of commitment and that's a good
thing that's it's necessary
that canadians pay
for certain goods would it be penalizing
canadians
to tell you
the impact
two canadians
in canada
after
encourage canadian companies foreign
tell canadian companies to not be active
russia
decisive move because
our government
putting pressure on russia it would be
an economic risk
for canada and canadian companies
to
[Music]
g7 countries
[Music]
strategically positioned economy
in our economy
and it was asia sweden
to act that way and i am pleased
that we can now
impose
sanctions
without truly impacting canadians
so it's an economic war against russia
right now correct japan's computing
measures that are stronger than ever
before continuing and that we will
continue to do so
is
internal affairs in russia to canada is
and to the russian people
against the
international order
and
at the same time
very important
[Music]
it is not an easy
thing to do
when you live
in a dictatorship
and i would like to say to those
courageous
russian people to those moral
russian people
you're not
ukrainian
my company would love to give thank jobs
ukrainians
there's
a strong
canadian support and it's
amazing
what the minister of immigration
announced
and that's
them yeah in english um look let me
first build upon the the comments um uh
that mr freeland just shared uh the
first reaction was uh
when my phone was blown up i saw a text
from my mom mom said she'd take six um
there are thousands of communities
filled with moms like that filled with
businesses filled with organizations
that want to help
my primary uh motivation uh was speed
my first reaction when i saw that there
was a potential influx of ukrainians who
would be seeking safe haven was to
figure out uh what can canada do can we
offer a refugee resettlement process
when i did get dug in on that i very
quickly realized that it would take
potentially years to settle people uh as
refugees and i was hearing from the
ukrainian community that people wanted
to come potentially temporarily not as
refugees
my second reaction was to look at a visa
waiver
when i actually examined the mechanics
that would be required to implement it i
discovered very quickly it was going to
require particular regulatory changes
and certain renovations to our i.t
system both internal to our department
and with airlines to actually recognize
through the electronic travel
authorization program we have for other
countries that have visa free travel and
it was going to take 12 to 14 weeks we
don't have 12 to 14 weeks we're going to
be able to stand up the new program i've
announced today much quicker than that
and start welcoming people uh in a more
expeditious way i should point out as
well that we do want to make sure that
canadians have faith we can manage this
in a professional way that protects our
security as you've suggested
when we made the decision to welcome an
unlimited number of applications we also
have to recognize that canadians want to
know that we're doing it in a
responsible way uh so those are the
reasons uh primarily speed but also
making sure canadians have faith we're
doing this in the safest possible way
i gotta go to the zoom line i'm sorry
because we're
if we can keep the answers tight then we
can maybe come back to the room but i
gotta go to the zoom so uh first up is
steven chase global mail
hi steve chase here global mail i just
want to follow up on my uh colleagues
question
um why didn't the visa the main feature
of a visa application that i'm
interested in is that it requires a
security check um
and i'm assuming that's part of the
reason why you kept the visa requirement
in place even though there's 60 other
countries and jurisdictions that get
visa free access to this country uh who
are you worried about um getting to this
country uh if there was no security
check that is are you worried about um
certain uh you know people may be
misrepresenting themselves and using
visa-free access to get to canada if you
were to drop that visa requirement
uh look uh thanks very much for the
question and i i think uh just to
reiterate uh when you do have a
complete visa waiver that means that
everyone can come uh who who is a
ukrainian national um it also opens the
door for others who might slip through
the cracks
we've heard concerns uh about certain
individuals such as those who've
supported and fought against the
ukrainian army and putin's war for the
past eight years in the donbass as well
those who are currently working against
ukraine and assisting russian troops by
having the biometric analysis we're
going to be able to screen out those as
is the case with all of our five rise
intelligence partners but we've been
prepared to deal with this and we
started moving additional biometric kits
into the region more than a month ago to
make sure that we have the capacity to
do this
i anticipate that we're going to be able
to process people in large numbers in a
very expeditious way and still protect
against that security risk of the people
who've actually been fighting against
ukrainians for the past eight years
and i will i will just relinquish my
follow-ups as you can go on
okay uh next up is
uh
my question is also for minister fraser
i would like
to give can you offer specifics please
uh
we may ask police
because i want to get the the details uh
accurately
so there's essentially two things in the
process that will be required uh one
a simple application form and two uh
biometrics
normally there would be additional uh
documents that would be required and
we've tried to pull a program off the
shelf simpler similar to our temporary
visa program and erode as many of the
administrative barriers as possible so
we can make it easier to get into the
program and make it quicker to process
in addition people will be eligible for
an open work permit when they arrive
there will be no requirement for a labor
market impact assessment there will be
no consideration of not codes there will
be no consideration of language
requirements you'll be able to work and
study as part of this program after you
arrive too
so we've essentially tried to look at
our programs that allow people to travel
to canada and allow them to work and
paired off as many administrative
barriers as possible so you just need to
submit the application form and then
submit your biometrics and then we can
deal with other elements after you're in
canada to the extent it may be necessary
according to your department
uh i'll answer your your questions in
reverse order so first
there
is no limit to the number of
applications that we are willing to
accept
the reason that we chose this particular
pathway is it's the same system that we
currently use to process uh in excess of
two million applications for temporary
visas a year it's the area where we have
the greatest horsepower and the fewest
administrative requirements that's going
to allow us to process whatever demand
we see
the application process is probably
going to open in about 14 days but i
should reiterate that the existing
temporary residence visa application
form is open and when we see any
applications from a ukrainian national
we have been pulling them out and
processing them first since january 19th
since january as of yesterday there were
6131 ukrainians that had already arrived
in canada we have been working very hard
to make it as quick as possible and if
there is an application not just for
permanent residency or temporary
residency but for proof of citizenship
for study permits for work permits any
application in irc system ircc system
that is attached to a ukrainian national
has been prioritized on a priority basis
uh since january 19th and we're going to
continue to do that up until the moment
the new application application system
goes live
okay uh next on the zoom line we're
going to go with david aiken from global
news
um thank you very much my question of
prime minister freeland
minister lots of uh members of the
gallery members of the press outside our
country have been writing about your
unique i don't know like i call like uh
heritage uh
attributes in helping to mobilize sort
of the international alliance against
this
i wonder if you might speak a little bit
about that your ability to speak you're
probably the only g20 i assume foreign
minister that speaks ukrainian that has
that background in russia could you
reflect a little bit about
that that bit of you in
dealing with this particular crisis
i don't really want to david because i
think our focus should be on the really
really brave people of ukraine
and i think they are the ones
who have turned this around
you know i think
that
when
it turned out that western deterrence
efforts hadn't worked and when putin
launched his barbaric attack on ukraine
a week ago just over a week ago
the sort of mainstream expert prediction
was that ukraine would fall
and it would fall very quickly
and
the ukrainians proved everybody to be
wrong
starting with president zielinski
and his i think it's going to go down in
his his historic line i need ammo not a
ride
and what we are seeing across ukraine
is a very very determined people
who have decided
they're willing to fight and die for
democracy and for freedom
and i think
that that
incredibly brave incredibly spirited
resistance
has
inspired the west i think the ukrainians
are the leaders now
and
you know i think
you could say maybe the west
western democracies
maybe we were kind of losing our mojo
you know we were getting a little bit
cynical
about
whether democracy really works
we were getting a little bit cynical
about
whether
regular people really care about
democracy and freedom
i think maybe we were getting a little
bit cynical about
the ability of democracies to act
together
quickly
and in a united way
and i think putin was counting on that i
think pukin and russian disinformation
actually for years now
has been trying to make us
in the west
cynical about democracy
and i think he thought his campaign had
been working
and i think maybe some of us fought that
too
and i think
and i speak for myself but i've heard
this from
many
leaders of other western countries and
non-western countries too you know the
kenyan
uh un ambassador made a remarkable
remarkable statement and i've heard it
from lots of canadians i think seeing
the ukrainians stand up and say
we may be smaller than you you may have
a fierce army that is bigger than ours
but we will not submit
i think that that is what has been
transformative
and i'm very proud of them
i'm very inspired by the people of
ukraine
and i think the whole world is
thanks for that maybe a quick follow-up
i wonder if you could speak to what i'll
call the
the arc of international enthusiasm to
apply sanctions we saw it was a little
slower maybe to get everybody with the
swift some of the banking actions today
you've announced revoking most favored
nation status by canada
would you expect our international
partners to be enthusiastic about
implying that
um yeah um you know david one of my
favorite
lines in literature is ernest
hemingway's line about someone going
broke and he talks about how it happens
gradually then all of a sudden
and i think in
human affairs
certainly
in geopolitics and in domestic politics
you sometimes reach a tipping point
and when you reach that tipping point
things that were previously impossible
become possible
i personally
observed that tipping point when i was
young as a reporter covering the
collapse of the soviet union
uh
in ukraine and then in russia
and
you know for someone who grew up in like
a super
stable canada hard to imagine a more
stable some people might even say more
boring country than ours i consider that
a compliment it's very good to live in a
stable sometimes boring country sort of
seeing that
incredibly
swift transformation and seeing how
every day what had been considered
impossible the day before
suddenly became possible
i remember that experience very clearly
and the past week has reminded me of
that
um
i have seen you know when it comes to
the sanctions the economic measures we
talked about a lot of stuff
uh
leading up to putin's invasion
and you know i would say the base
assumption was we're going to try
deterrence
but if deterrence doesn't work if we
don't persuade putin not to do this
then you know ukraine is probably lost i
i think that was the basic assumption
and what's happened now is
everyone is up for everything
and i think it's because the ukrainians
have
given us all hope
that they might actually hang in there
and so seeing them fight so bravely
makes the rest of us think
gee like the least we can do is use the
strongest possible economic tools we
have is have our minister of defense and
her colleagues
supply
all of the weapons that ukrainians need
and have sean and his colleagues
take care of the ukrainians who have to
flee ukraine so i do think david i think
there has been a transformation it's an
entirely different atmosphere
instead of countries talking about
reasons that something is too hard to do
there is now a real creativity in the
meetings and people are kind of saying
hey what about this and then someone
will say what about that
and i think uh that you are seeing that
in this sort of constant introduction of
new measures
so canada definitely is playing a role
there
uh i would say other countries have
recognized that we have a certain
ukraine and russia expertise um and so
we're definitely part of the
brainstorming
and you know watch this space there's a
lot more to come and maybe the final
thing i'll say is it's not just about
government leaders at this point
the other thing that has happened which
i really welcome and encourage
is we are seeing
regular
we are seeing a lot of companies
stepping up
and saying i just don't want to do
business with russia anymore
and i think that's great as well
okay we got time for one more i'm gonna
come back to the room now so sorry to
everybody on the zoom line but i'm gonna
come back to the room david you're gonna
get the the last question here cbc
can you tell us what is the latest on
the 3400 troops on standby are they
ready to move on short notice
and
why not move them now as suggested
david
the 3 400 troops
are part of the pledges that
canada
makes to nato
and made to nato in january when we were
foreseeing that a further russian
invasion may indeed be possible in
addition to the 3 400 troops we also
pledged for example naval and some air
capability
and
the reality is
all of that is on standby and when
the supreme allied commander
at nato
as well as the nato allies make
decisions about
calling up or drawing down on those
pledges
that's when they will move they are on
high readiness alert
as
they must be in case our nato
organization calls upon our country in
this way
but they are not moving at the current
time and we will wait until we hear from
the supreme allied commander of europe
in nato
to make that decision
question i think this is for you
minister anan experts have said it would
be illegal
for foreign fighters to become fighters
for russia so to go to ukraine to fight
for russia
um not ukraine
would canada prosecute
canadians who go over to ukraine to
fight for russia
well i'll
start and i'll hand the floor over to
the deputy prime minister
of course we understand canadians desire
to join our ukrainian friends to fight
our role as a federal government is to
ensure that we are providing accurate
information to all of our
citizens relating to security situations
around the world
and i will take a moment to say that if
there are canadians who are interested
in
the armed forces the canadian armed
forces
is currently recruiting
and we would very much welcome
applications from across the country
to the canadian armed forces where we
have had a
training mission in ukraine since 2015
and have trained over 33 000 ukrainian
soldiers so i would say
at this time
the
legalities
of the situation reflected in your
question
are indeterminate at this time
we need to focus on the present and as a
government our job is to provide
accurate information to canadians and
that's exactly what we're doing and
we'll continue to do every single day
christian
okay anita so i will just add first of
all
it is wonderful uh to have uh
an esteemed uh lawyer and former law
professor as our minister of defense in
this time
i think your question was about people
who fight on the russian side
and
i'm sure people know that our colleague
our foreign minister melanie jolie
announced in geneva this week that
canada will petition the icc
against russia for crimes against
humanity and war crimes
we are very clear
that this war
is illegal
and
canada
will take
a very
appropriately
severe view
of anyone who is fighting this war
i do want to say um
something i've been hearing from
ukrainians actually people in the
ukrainian government is
how sorry they feel for some of uh the
russian recruits who are fighting there
um there's a real sense that some of
them are very young
some of them didn't even know
that they were apparently didn't even
didn't know they were going into a war
didn't even know that they would be
fighting in ukraine
and
uh i feel so sorry for them
uh they've really been sent into a meat
grinder
to support
one man's
you know barbaric effort to undermine
democracy i feel sorry for their
families
that's not the case for the architects
of this war
that's not the case for people who make
a voluntary choice to aid and abet this
war
and then you know we've been talking
about
the unity of western countries and not
just western countries of the world's
democracies in condemning russia and
supporting ukraine
and i think
there is reason
to celebrate that unity it's a really
good thing
but
i think in conclusion
it's worth it for all of us
to
remember how costly in terms of human
lives devastated families
cities neighborhoods this war has
already been
and
there is every reason to believe
it's going to get worse
and a lot more people are going to die
and you know we as canadians um
need to brace ourselves for that it's
already been a bloodbath i think it's
going to become more of a bloodbath
i'm sure i'm not the only person who
wakes up in the middle of the night just
to check
that kuv is still okay that kharkiv is
still okay
and
they i think we have some terrible
nights ahead
and
we need to also
really
be
remember the human tragedy here even as
we celebrate
the
incredible strength
and resilience of the people of ukraine
unfortunately it's all the time we have
thanks everybody for coming today mister
thank you very much for your time
you